[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen
heute gibt es ein lexus top craft ich
werde mit cupcakes machen die
wirtschaftskapitäne gibt es heute noch
zehnmal hintereinander
der kopf des glücklich bist du zu sagen
ich hab schon ewig nicht gegessen ich
glaube zwar dass kindheit und ich habe
auch hab ich grad beim bak netz gestellt
ich habe früher meist eher gelassen hat
eigentlich kaum noch bei dir auch so ins
programm passen gewartet doch es stimmt
was mit mir los ist auch lässt geht's ja
auch vor sich jetzt kaum noch böses aber
ich bete für diese zugleich legt auch
war heute kit clubs cupcakes gebacken
sie bestehen aus aluminium gibt hört zu
machen nach in kraft getreten und an dem
gipfel will oder und natürlich sind bei
heftig so ist würde versagen der
kalorien beruf gelegt wollte gleich nur
die dinge angucken nicht essen
aber mit den sehr lecker und ich frage
mich auch an geeigneter stelle wo er
zuletzt ein bisschen abspecken kann aber
ich muss dazu sagen der flüssige
karamell can war der wunsch von borat im
erlebt habe und deswegen fragen sich
jetzt einmal die zutaten für die macht
mit macht ins treibhaus 150 zocker einer
prise salz etwas vanille extrakt und 60
com mail 30 kakaopulver anhalten
teelöffel backpulver und wikinger film
art von 150 gramm öl habe ich 50 bis 60
gramm butter mit bayern und westkap erst
einmal damit es auch nicht unbedingt
optimal nehmen einfach irgendein lakers
gewechselt zeitung mit waffeln und
formulare im privatbesitz aus und wie
könnte jetzt entweder mit dem messer
klein schneiden oder auch mit dem alle
karten
[Musik]
sie werfen tieren statt dieses mal ganz
kurz zur seite jetzt nehme ich erst mal
alle restlichen zutaten und die
vermische tier sonst geht alles mit
einem nassen handtuch gerät oder
maschine dass wir einfach kurven im
backofen oder mit einem normalen kochen
verriet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn ich getroffen und verbindet sie
miteinander
also mädels zucker backpulver natron bis
machen jederzeit richtig toll aus ein
bisschen verteilen das fleisch besser in
der luft
[Musik]
er kommt nur noch vanille extrakt dann
kommen die trockenen zutaten mit den
massen zutaten alles schön verdient
[Musik]
jetzt verteidigt den teig mit einem
einfachen heroins maschinchen und dann
kommentare gibt
[Musik]
die
wirklichkeit stücke drücke ich es ganz
leise sein und dann können wir machen
vor heißen backofen bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze etwa frauen gebacken werden
[Musik]
die muffins ist abgekühlt und schaffte
noch in kleine rote lämpchen gesetzt und
jetzt hab ich so weiter verarbeiten wenn
ihr es nur gibt topteams haben wollt
dann lasst so stimmte auch gerät ist
wunderschön aber für uns war das top
drauf
deswegen habe ich jetzt eine creme
vorbereite sich hier mal die zutaten für
die 10 bis 200 smart fan zweites unserer
paar 250 später im doppel ramslohs zwar
ersten fotos 34 sonderfahrt etwas sonne
lag 86 zum start haben sie es zwei große
genommen du erst wenn jetzt cup nehmen
unter klein und ich mache ich einfach in
den mixer weil sie keine micro habt
könnt ihr sie auch in gefrierbeutel
stecken und austausch darüber rollt
drüber rollen und raucher
[Musik]
hier stellte ganz kurz zur seite und
kann zumal die sahne nehmen und ein
bisschen früher
und da kommt dann mit bonaparte mit
einem schlag
[Applaus]
susannes auf den frischkäse und verhöre
ihnen dann auch noch mit puderzucker auf
meine lady könnte es an dieser stelle
zum beispiel auch mal stuff ohne nehmen
aber ich bin grad die frischkäse passt
gut aus sowohl einfach so leicht salzig
ist und dann eben diese perfekt
ausgleich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die fische sind neben geschmeide vom
design und die kinder entweder mit farbe
unterheben
[Musik]
muss nur aufpassen und darf damit nicht
zu lange wollen sie sagen nicht gerinnt
und sie fangen wir noch die gibt es ein
weil sie das nicht mehr könnt ihr die
creme auch als social und verwenden so
schmeckt wie allerdings wenigstens wenig
zucker verwendet da eben die prügel mit
rein kommt aber die machen jetzt eine
schöne optik und auch noch tolle texte
hatte einstein
[Musik]
die kriege ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer großen stern
schule ein
die schrecklich so lecker die tore
verschlossen hat diese kleinen pfeilen
stock stützen mit dringt jedoch erst
später sorgte vergeben wirklich gut lief
es hier noch einen zweiten spritzbeutel
und da hab ich ein loch thüle dran und
war für mich seit meiner selbst gemachte
karamellsoße einfach findet ihr das
rezept auch bereit auf meinem kanal und
ob man im blog wissen stellt erstmals an
seite und fortschrittlich die prämie wie
einen kleinen donuts hier herum damit
praktisch in der mitte eröffnung bleibt
für die karamellsoße
[Musik]
in diese öffnung sei jetzt karamellsoße
ein ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch
weglassen was macht das ganze bitte lies
mit karamellsoße ist natürlich nur avg
und schwimmt auf die toilette und oft
sehr gut zu den machen und für
schokolade
[Musik]
nein noch nicht gemacht halo reach jetzt
kommt es noch dicker würfel drauf werdet
ihr noch mal ein paar kids karte klein
gewürfelt und die kommen jetzt als deko
um das topping hier oben drauf
[Musik]
die cases aus und ich würde mal sagen
gedacht vielleicht probieren oder
absolut jetzt nicht den kompletten auf
einmal auf aber auch andere ursachen mit
waffeln sich mehrheitlich hinter dem man
kann auch zwei typen aufeinander zum
essen sowieso gestatten motion aufnehmen
ist oder war
ich mag halt und saftigen zeigt für die
machen finde ich super vorschlagen den
geschmack textur in deinem und finde ich
creme als fußballer also ich hab die
freund schon ein bisschen gelächelt und
könnte als eigene website
ich glaube in kombination mit karamell
omega oder vielleicht auch die im mini
portion machen dh die mini muffin
förmchen nehmen haben wir nur eine halbe
packte mich auf jeden fall solle auch
helfen wenn sie nicht frieren
ich musste viel zu gucken genau das
machen es ist echt cool also macht nicht
mehr
man hat ihr dann noch um den schokohasen
dann noch die gibt's obendrauf
deswegen sehr lecker und ich bin nicht
wegsehen so toll dass die schokolade am
ende auf der zunge schmilzt zwar nicht
obwohl durch chance für jeden fall könnt
ihr das hat selbst gerne nachlesen auch
verließen ist da stets noch mal ganz
genau
und falls es nach macht könnt ihr in
farben und verlinken ich schaue mir
gerne an so viel spaß machen und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]